we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail from someone very clearly
owning the libs because of Bernie's
hypocrisy take a listen
hey David this is Jim from Mississippi
just want to say that our communist
Bernie Sanders is a hypocrite the D
flies on private jets but he talks about
all this carbon emissions but on top of
that
hey bruh him Lincoln he they hypocrite
too right
I mean he's over here wearing these
cotton clothes all these clothes may
pick my plate but he's against slavery
I'll keep you against slavery and then
wear cotton clothes you should be
wearing anything yeah listen I don't
know anything about Abraham Lincoln's
slave picked cotton clothes what I can
tell you about Bernie Sanders is what I
care about is policy I don't care if a
candidate is rich or poor a priori what
I care about is what are their policies
going to do for the average person if
Bernie Sanders were regularly flying on
a private jet I think that there would
be a critique in there of course this
person throwing in Bernie's a communist
and he flies on private jets bernie is
obviously not a communist my
understanding is Bernie flew on a
private jet a few times because of the
scheduling requirements around the
Senate impeachment trial of Donald Trump
and possibly some sort of last-minute
campaign things that are going on by the
way every president flies on a private
jet eventually and there would be you
know the the are we going to say that no
president should do that either I know
that the Mexican president for some time
was actually flying fly flying
commercial the practicalities of it
listen if Bernie if Bernie doesn't
denounce Air Force One as president and
continues to fly Air Force One but he
actually fixes our tax system and
improves health care and makes education
more accessible to people I don't care
about flying on Air Force One I know
private jets are absolutely destructive
on a per passenger basis to the
environment there is no doubt about it
I'm with you on that but that's not what
this person is talking about this person
is just looking to attack people I care
about policy and I support people
on the basis of the policies that they
proposed this is like but Bernie's three
houses and we dealt with that a couple
of weeks ago come on let's focus on
policy we've got a great bonus show for
you today join us
the last pre Super Tuesday bonus show
join pakman.com or patreon.com slash
david pakman show to get instant access
to that bonus show we'll talk about the
new Obamacare case before the Supreme
Court we'll talk about how China's air
pollution has dropped during the virus
quarantine and we will talk about Trump
defending continuing to hold rallies as
the virus spreads all of those stories
and more today including my I voted
story coming up as well